if you are into anime or even animation
in general let me introduce you to
sakuga boru the ultimate resource for
animation behind the scenes this website
is upca by animation fans that are quite
frankly insanely knowledgeable the
entire thing is a collection of fan
submitted Cuts or clips from animated
material that are organized by who
animated them specifically deeply
dedicated fans are able to piece
together who animated watch by multiple
means from the animators confirming
things online all the way to cross
referencing episodes staff list and
piecing together individual animators
Styles there are literally people on
this site that can tell you who animated
this scene based on the way this ear is
drawn alone you can search the website
by animator series or even types of
Animation like effects work hand-to-hand
combat or production material it really
is just a wonderful resource for anyone
interested in animation and a testament
to the undy dedication and passions of
the human race